and II give you good celebrity jeopardy
advice yes I because you were mentioning
that I hadn't seen you in a while and I
always think of you because I don't know
that I've been able to thank you for
your celebrity jeopardy advice no I
don't
okay Inez was use your iPhone and this
may have been pre iPhone when I did it
but I was about to go in celebrity
jeopardy when I had come to see you on
the old show and you said that the the
clicking technique is vital yes and that
women in particular or maybe I'm just
remembering that hold their thumb up
like this and so the guys for when the
next time you're on Jeopardy then the
distance between your thumb and the
clicker thing is too far and you so that
you should be like this and so instead
of going like this I was like this and I
came in second great
Andy you said women hit the button wrong
is that what you said no I don't like
the way Andy's treating women Frank I'm
mad about late night and about like some
you know it's the only way I'm sexist is
the width the way women hold the buzzer
on that GD told you that just by
observation or something that there's I
don't know why you would I don't know
I'm just gonna go like this a lot the
rest of this are you allowed to be
touching the buzzer I don't know it's a
thing that you hold in your hand with a
button on right yeah yeah but you can
have both fingers on ya all the time
some but you can see people that hold it
above and then they go yeah oh I think I
just broke the cow
before
[Applause]
I'll be all right
[Laughter]
clearly like it clearly like Aaron it
look at that there's like a bolt
sticking out kind of shitty show is this
you still want to talk show so this is
ridiculous
you okay anyway I better go home no no
any oh oh you sit up I'm gonna prank
prank lets back in there okay hold on a
second how cold
okay there we go no it's not going yes
all right
[Applause]
no more clicking wildly that's never
happened you just mentioned Chanel two
years we've been here 22 years the couch
has never broke you know I actually
broke it once but I didn't notice until
the commercial break
what do you know are you doing on the
know we've been doing it a bit or
something where I had to fly back on
like fall back on the couch like I had
been killed or something that's who it's
all the wash but I thought I broke the
back leg of this couch before I was
doing you know a full you know walrus
body flop yeah this I was just going
like why I should
[Applause]
and there it goes that's great Andy
that's great
yeah sticking around Lauren you can sit
right